welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about what it's
like to have a relationship with a gooey
monster that wants to eat every living
thing it sees while also fixing all your
health problems really nice goo i like i
like a good health problem-solving goo
my name is mt and i'm here today with
off-screen producer brandon what's going
on brandon hello mt not much going on
just you know waiting in the dark room
for you to call me out and put me on
camera anytime i can get it we put
brandon in the closet when we're done
shooting these and like yeah this is
brandon closet he does all this research
he comes out we do a big question
together that's right not really that's
please don't come after us it's like
it's like pulp fiction bring out the
[ __ ] here he comes
you kids might be too young for pulp
fiction but it was a great movie in
1994.
children educate yourselves go watch the
film classics
com forward slash
of tarantino well if you're trying if
you're a child don't watch it maybe uh
wait till you're of of age but anyway
hit me with that big question brandon
okay mt you and i are back together
again talking about what else but venom
let there be carnage okay and now we got
a new symbiote entering the sony
spider-verse venomverse whatever we want
to call it uh carnage is here we got
another symbiote symbiote and now like
we have like these two symbiotes along
with like some of the other symbiotes
we've seen in the first film there was
like riot right and there's like buddies
on the comet um
so they all seem to have their own like
personalities and abilities but my
question is empty like what about these
people inside the symbiotes you know
what's what's life like for them are
they just wearing like big goose suits
like how does it all work so that leads
us to this week's big question
how does the physiology of venom and
carnage work
how does it work
that's right folks venom let there be
carnage has finally made its way to
theaters and if you haven't seen it yet
you may want to do that first before
continuing this episode because why
would you do that why would you do that
to yourself
it's into spoiler territory so consider
this your warning spoiler warning we're
always giving the spoiler warnings
seriously we don't want to spoil
anything about those fancy goo suits
yeah i want to hear it i don't want to
give suits postcards emails you spoiled
it for me
seriously because if we do
there's going to be carnage
whoa let there be carnage i'm just it's
not a threat it's a promise okay so i
got some goo in my closet oh my god
anyway i don't know why that's
[Music]
please
your landlord's gonna charge you for
that when you move out if you leave goo
in the car
seriously uh it's it's black light stuff
that's what i'm talking about that's
disgusting
like star-lord said jackson pollock
painting everywhere that's the grossest
moment
oh my god i'm so sorry for whoever edits
the episodes
last week i went on a tangent for like
two minutes yeah you knew off the real
segment here okay you you're you're in
space peter quill you have like access
to all sorts of crazy technology get
your ship cleaned for god's sakes
exactly there's gotta be some sort of
like quantum cleaning service on on like
zandar or one of those planets take it
in get it get the full you know the hand
wash you know detailing get it all
seriously and clean up go to contraction
grab one of those sex robots and be like
hey here's a i don't want sex yeah yeah
he's a broom he's a swiffer go to town
um on my room please
[Laughter]
oh my god anyway get that get the train
back on the
uh on the rails please back out of the
tracks back on that's like doctor
strange and spiderman in the trailer no
don't get off the tracks again stay on
the track but yes both venom and carnage
are symbiotes but how they interact with
our host bodies has some differences
because while carnage may be the
offspring of venom referring to him as
father during one of their battles it
has definitely taken its own unique path
when it comes to attaching to and
interacting with a person so let us dive
into these murderous puddles of goo to
see if we can figure out the anatomy of
these alien symbiotes starting with
venom our hero villain of the you know
franchise venom yeah he's like uh he's a
villain technically but he's also the
hero because in these movies he's got
yeah more evil things to fight so i
guess by default he's our protagonist
he's our hero yes in the sony films
venom and the other symbiotes originally
came from outer space and they were
found by the life foundation living
peacefully on a comet sailing through
the stars but of course like we saw in
the suicide squad dumb humans had to
intervene and brought the symbiotes to
earth and eventually that's how our boy
eddie brock found himself the host to
the venom symbiote but when eddie is in
venom form where is he exactly well much
like tony stark or bruce banner inside
of the hulkbuster armor good old eddie
brock is just kind of inside the venom
goo armor when he's in venom forming you
can kind of get a good sense of this in
the first movie when he's coming out of
the venom form to talk to anne but also
when venom peels back his face to reveal
eddie inside to deliver the we are venom
line to the robber the venom we see in
the films is not quite as bulky and huge
as the comic version of venom because
the comic version of venom can often be
as almost big as a room so the idea of
eddie floating inside of that venom does
feel a little bit silly you're totally
right mt like i remember when like when
it venom's like in the thunderbolts a
few years ago he was so big and just to
think of a little eddie brock sitting
inside of there like
my venom neck i'm in my venom suit
but yeah like in the in the films like
he's he's like big but he's it's kind of
just like they put like eddie brock on
like you know platform shoes because
like when he gets
dissolves out to like talk to anne like
you were saying in that first movie he's
just kind of like yeah
and he's like a little [ __ ] taller than
when he's venom yeah he's just like a
little bit bigger a little bit beefier
but the comments like he's always like
huge
it almost makes me think like yeah with
like the hulkbuster armor it doesn't
seem like bruce or or tony's arms could
even like get to the arms like that's
how big that thing is
it's like
[Laughter]
so i kind of like that the movies didn't
make him like so big because it would
seem silly that he's just like inside of
there
seriously kind of like the ninja turtles
did in the recent reboots they made the
turtles for no reason they were like why
you don't have to do that you just make
them slightly bigger than your average
turtle okay you don't gotta do it crazy
like it's a big
gooey monster with a huge tongue and
teeth like we're afraid of it it doesn't
have to be huge it doesn't have to be
like seriously like it's i've already
it's the teeth i'm afraid of i'm not
afraid of them
yeah
as long as the teeth is there i'm good
but when not in venom form the symbiote
does live inside of eddie and depending
on how you view having a carnivorous
sentient alien symbiote living inside of
you this is pretty advantageous for
eddie all things considered i guess yeah
there's benefits there's it's a
symbiotic relationship there's some
benefits here even though he does call
him like a parasite as like a joke venom
really does not like that he's not a
parasite what you can't call me that
you know what i only swooch off your
life force what are you talking about
i fixed your broken legs give me some
credit the symbiote is able to give
eddie extremely incredible regenerative
powers with both wounds and broken limbs
being fixed instantaneously and if you
follow the logic of the comics the
symbiote could even regrow limbs on
eddie for example in the comics the
symbiote regrew the legs of flash
thompson when they bonded so if someone
chopped off eddie's arm the venom
symbiote should be able to regrow it
sort of like how you know the iron man 3
uh what do you call it the extremists
guys yeah yeah it's almost like the
extremist project in iron man 3. it's
such a big plot point in like comic
books like the lizard you know he was
trying to regrow stuff he's honest guys
trying to regrow stuff why is everyone
losing limbs all over the place
seriously keep your limbs intact hang on
to your limbs folks also in the comics
eddie brock was dying of cancer but when
the symbiote came along it was able to
get rid of the cancer in eddie brock
which is holy crap that's the miracle
cure i feel i really hope that they
follow like the logic of something like
that because like the life foundation
originally i'm sure was supposed to you
know better the world with the with
their findings of what they found in
space so like if they
like we're like hey the venom whatever
the symbiote is is able to like heal
people in these magical ways i feel like
that would really help
maybe just like bolster the the
universe's interest in acquiring this
symbiote for themselves for their own
use because like you see a lot in marvel
movies of people trying to use science
for their own monetary gain or
just to maybe benefit society and it
just goes wrong mt you see it in real
life too those pharmaceutical companies
trying to make money off of us
[Music]
i will say empty if you name your
company the life foundation i'm gonna be
suspicious it sounds yeah like you're up
to something it does sound a little too
good to be true right are you making
cereal in there what's going on life
foundation
i don't know yeah it would be
interesting if they you know with the
eddie brock having cancer in the comics
like it would be interesting if they
introduced it in the films
so it's probably too late now right
because he already has a symbiote so
like it couldn't ever start he couldn't
just like magically get cancer one day
because the symbiote in theory is always
like fighting off these illnesses and
whatever diseases might come his way he
would have to like be separated for for
a long time maybe they'll give
eventually or maybe they'll give it to
like anne and he'll be like you get to
be lady venom again because well anne
was briefly venom instrument venom one
boy
was she
that extra long tongue oh if you know
what i'm being i don't know what that
means okay anyway all right um
which though even though
let's derail the train again real fast
empty
uh lady venom okay cause like venom
still has its own personality as this
symbiote and so he's on anne and i think
he's getting a little bit of ann's
personality right but i think he's
taking that opportunity to kiss
kiss old eddie brock
he knows what he venom knows what it's
doing he knew what he was doing he was
like he was like i love this house like
this
look at this body come on give me a give
me a kiss yeah it's like never leave me
again baby oh baby he makes out with
them so hey i i support this bromance
yeah it's nice it's nice to kiss the
homies every now and then you know what
i mean it's not gay to kiss the homies
on the mouth of tongue is kissing the
homies gay
a little bit
it's also important to note that when
eddie is in normal form he's able to
take more bumps and bruises than he
would have been able to before being
bonded with venom so you don't even have
to be fully suited up to take advantage
of having the symbiote at that point i
actually really like mtv because so
often in like comics and like the movies
you know it'll be you know like tony's a
normal guy inside the iron man suit
he's taking a lot of bumps and bruises
and they don't really explain how other
than like there's kind of this universal
understanding that to be a hero whoever
you are you have that little extra open
side of you that gives you the drive to
push through pain push through the
injuries but come on people take bumps
and bruises they're going to be down for
the count i actually like that the venom
symbiote you know just being inside of
eddie makes him stronger so that you
know when you see eddie brock get
stabbed through the chest
like in the first movie it makes sense
that he's
able to bounce back a little bit because
he has this symbiote like giving him
strength giving and power even when he's
not like fully suited up
i don't know why it covered my face
fully suited
the universal sign for i'm wearing
medusa that's like yes that's asl for
venom
set it up dude i would love to have a
venom symbiote just to heal my injuries
because brandon i i slipped and fell on
some ice in january and i'm still
feeling that [ __ ] to this day i'm sorry
my greatest nemesis is the box grater
okay we're familiar you're making nachos
you gotta shred some cheese you have the
shred side you know you have the side
which was a little finer shred you have
that other side which gives you like the
slices and then you have that side that
i think is meant to crumble cheese it's
just like the box grid has a bunch of
sharp little points i can't touch a box
grater without ripping my thumb open on
that side i can't avoid it it's the most
dangerous tool in the kitchen guys burn
your body be the symbiote we need a
symbiote just so i can cook and make
nachos without bleeding to death please
how do you keep your pants up when
you're performing it's incredible
built who cares if society ends if the
world ends i need to not get cut yes
goddamn [ __ ] thank you and the symbiote
is also capable of replicating clothing
so in theory eddie would never have to
buy new clothes ever again though i
suppose the disadvantage of this would
be that if you ever were to get and
fight with your symbiote as it was
providing you clothing then you know
it would probably just take your
clothing away and you would just be nude
yeah on the street it would just shrink
back inside of you and be like you're
you're on your own now buddy make your
own seriously i think your your penis
size reverts back to normal size when
the venom from the symbiote leaves so oh
again i'm so sorry we apologize anyway
yeah i would like to see
the venom in the film like start doing
like clothing that would be cool uh
because i know like in the comics when
like you know peter parker was
originally wearing like the black suits
needed to be peter parker and this suit
just kind of made peter parker's clothes
for him it was like
peter parker again like how you know you
need to go to a wedding after work
just perfectly boom it just changes
automatically you're going from cocktail
party to night at the club
right hey change oh my god it's the
dream it's the dream i hate
buying new clothes and having to
try the mod and i make sure that it's
just when one venom suit one symbiote
suit fits all that's why the fashion
industry keeps us out of space they
don't want us to find the symbiotes
seriously never have to buy clothes
again it's kylie jenner it's all the
it's all the kardashians it's all that
kind of keeping us out of space they
know they know would you stop taking
pictures of yourself your sister's going
to jail it's fast fashion keeping us out
of the skies i'm looking at you h m
the film version of the eddie venom
symbiotic relationship certainly allows
eddie to maintain a lot of control over
what happened bad guy right yep
oh and often in the comics eddie
describes it as going to sleep when
venom takes over and more of like a
jekyll and hyde type situation but since
the film are portraying venom as more of
an anti-hero they're letting eddie keep
some control over what happens so
probably in an effort to avoid a
situation where venom is just going
around eating everybody and you know
eddie's just like oh yeah this is fine
totally fine yeah they have to like keep
venom in control because i mean
obviously with
comics you know whoever's writing the
story you know characters powers and
abilities they're going to change a lot
but it does seem a lot in the comics we
have eddie
yeah he's either like drowning or like
kind of going to sleep when like venom's
in control but i'm kind of glad that
it's not like that here because that
would just be kind of too much like
original hulk where you have like banner
not knowing like hulk's up to it seems
like most of the time when venom is
speaking it's really eddie speaking
through venom like if he's fully suited
up you know but i guess in theory venom
could just say something on his own and
eddie would be inside being like i
didn't say that like don't don't do it
for me um but he's he's fully conscious
he's not like asleep when it's happening
which is yeah like yeah yeah and i feel
like that does make sense considering
that they are a symbiotic yeah and like
they and venom does like to use the term
we
when he's talking
[Music]
so like it would be weird if this if
he's saying we and like the other
person's asleep it's like yeah we
appreciate yeah it's like no it's like
you guys are both occupying the same
space at the same time which i do like
versus like you said hulk where it's
just like one person is in control but
brandon how does eddie eat and breathe
because when eddie's in venom form he's
just kind of just floating in this black
goo but how is he able to breathe in the
goo because he's obviously getting
oxygen somehow or else he'd just die in
a matter of minutes because you know we
need oxygen on this planet unfortunately
until you know technology fixes that and
we're just just going straight off the
wi-fi um anyway we're addicted to oxygen
we can't help it exactly give me that
5g to keep me alive that's all i need
give it 5g straight
the comics seem to explain that the
symbiote is able to provide oxygen to
its host in fact when in the symbiote
suit the host is able to breathe in a
very hospitable environment like
underwater or in outer space and what's
interesting is that the first venom film
established that the symbiotes needed an
oxygen breathing host in order to
survive on our planet though we have now
seen that the symbiote can exist on its
own without a host so perhaps it has
been able to adapt after being bonded
with the host on earth for so long to
add to the mt i i did think it was
interesting that the venom movies made
that weird establishment of like oh
these symbiotes need an oxygen breathing
host to be on this planet i don't think
that was ever the case in the comics i
could be mistaken uh but i i think you
know i think the filmmakers did it as
like a plot contrivance of these are why
the symbiotes are so eager to get onto a
host and it kind of makes sense if they
were living in space you know we don't
know where the symbiotes come from in
the sony venomverse you know we might
get there who knows florida if they come
from florida i wouldn't doubt it uh
people keep questioning don't flush your
antibiotics down the toilet folks this
is how we get symbiosis that's how you
get sick that's how you get symbiotes in
order to be on a planet it would make
sense that they need to attach to like
whatever living organism is on that
planet in earth it's they needed to
breathe the oxygen but on like a planet
like venus which has a non-oxygen
atmosphere i don't remember what it is
nitrogen
sulfur i don't know they were if there
were living things on venus i'm not
saying there are but i'm not saying
there aren't then the symbiote would
have to like attach to that living thing
to be able to survive on that planet
that kind of makes sense
scientifically right wait so what you're
saying is that there are living things
on venus gotcha yes definitely confirmed
[Music]
so you heard it here first the truth is
out there brandon has announced
living life on venus
living
but brandon what happens when venom eats
something does eddie brock eat it too
and we've actually covered this in a
bite-sized question on an episode a few
months ago but let us quickly recap what
we know about venom's digestive system i
do remember this i think i remember this
yeah and so i've been here long enough
that i'm like remembering the passwords
now oh my congratulations empty i'm part
of the crew now oh boy when venom eats
something or someone thankfully those
num nums do not go to eddie's digestive
system because according to the comic
venom number seven from 2018 the maker
explains to eddie brock that the green
slime extruded by the venom symbiote is
actually it's waste product
i don't know why i said that with such a
good step so that means that the
symbiote absorbs whatever it eats
bypassing its host digestive system and
that's probably a good thing though the
comics have established that the host
can taste with the symbiote east so
that's not great um to be able to taste
human flesh even though you're not
digesting it don't want to eat my
neighbor please won't you
my neighbor cause what if it tastes
really good and then you're gonna be
like wow right i guess i'll eat a person
like [ __ ] now i didn't know people
tasted so good now i gotta start eating
whenever feasible one should always try
to eat the root but we kind of saw this
in the first venom film when venom eats
that robber at the end and then
transform into eddie licking his lips
yeah you know it's kind of anyone tasty
human flesh he's just licking his lips
like i think he liked it a little bit
you're right empty this is like a really
good thing because you wouldn't want i
don't know if you could digest if the
human body could digest like the bones
of like another person like no way no
way yeah probably not but it but it does
like so like venom absorbs it but then
like goes into your body i don't know i
don't know it's it's pretty crazy i
don't know this is exactly why i like my
people boneless
i like boneless strictly boneless people
on my pizza yeah pizza what you want let
me get a
boneless pizza boneless people mt just
makes me think of that super disturbing
scene in harry potter and the chamber of
secrets when gilroy lockhart magically
makes harry's bone disappear and like
bends his arm backward
disgusting barf every time i see it it's
the most disturbing boneless humans ever
been putting delicious
delicious even more delicious when
you're the boy who lived i guess it kind
of makes it because this is an alien
symbiote so we don't know how fast its
digestive system works so maybe it like
instantly absorbs what it's eating it
just so quickly goes into the
bloodstream gets extruded as green slime
or slime and then goes back into eddie's
body real fast
and eddie just tastes the tasty human a
little bit of flesh on the tongue
delicious i feel like that would make
sense for for eddie's body to
be able to just process energy really
fast because yeah he needs the energy
the symbiote needs the energy for all
the crazy [ __ ] that he likes to do so
yeah he loves to do that crazy [ __ ]
that crazy [ __ ] he's like okay i came
here to do crazy [ __ ] eddie
i could do all this crazy [ __ ]
i don't like it on venus it's boring
there
my parents want me to get a job so i
came to earth to just do some crazy [ __ ]
i would really love if venom really was
just like
cuz because he said he was a loser on
his planet like if you just had parents
it's like where did venom go he's just
like evading his responsibilities or
something venomous
i'm not gonna clean my room
i'm going to earth crazy [ __ ]
but what about carnage does this
symbiote operate in the same way as
venom well yes and no because carnage is
an offspring of venom the next
generation if you will this is also true
in the comics where eddie and cletus
were in the same prison venom helped
eddie escape but left behind a little
baby offspring that bonded to cletus and
the film takes a different approach
where cletus is a little bit more
aggressive in his absorption of the
symbiote when he bites eddie brock and
gets a taste of that new batch of blood
he gets the symbiote directly into his
own bloodstream and this makes the bond
happen in the blood rather than through
the nervous system as it happens in the
other symbiotes because of the type of
bomb that cletus and carnage make they
are much more closely bonded and harder
to separate and this also explains why
cartage and cletus refer to themselves
as eye rather than the more inclusive we
that eddie and venom use and this fusion
at the blood cell level also helps
explain why carnage is a reddish color
but is cletus inside of carnage like
eddie is inside of venom well not really
because if he watched the
transformations closely instead of
forming a suit around his host cletus's
whole body grotesque league morphs into
carnage so that further emphasizes the
bond that cletus and carnage have which
is kind of disgusting and gross yeah
it's like kind of crazy to think about
because it's you know it's easy to
visualize like eddie inside of his
little venom goo suit but the fact that
carnage is just like it's almost like um
inside out boys just like his blood and
guts are
uh uh carnage and it's it's crazy it's
it's a little harder to conceptualize
but i think it makes sense i feel like
eddie got really lucky that that wasn't
the case for him because i feel is the
vicipio it's gonna come and take over my
body i'm assuming that like my whole i'm
changing on a molecular cellular level
like i'm just done and like i'm be i'm
now a different being so like with
cletus i feel like this is more like oh
yeah this is the worst case scenario
right here this is oh this is the
symbiote you do not want at all
could the fact that carnage was awakened
by the lethal injection mean that he's
more aggressive than venom it's possible
because cletus was nearly killed that
carnage feels more personally attacked
because remember that they are very
closely bonded and we do see a couple of
the vials of the lethal injection
cocktail are administered before the
symbiote fights back so maybe he would
have been a little nicer if he didn't
start off almost being poisoned feel
like that very jarring moment of cletus
cassidy almost being executed was like
you know what let's just [ __ ] around the
entire nervous system yeah like he's
about to die let's just take over yeah
probably pissed off the symbiote like a
lot like because yeah you see like i
think like two almost three of those
those like plungers are pushed down of
like the
lethal injection cocktail uh and i know
it's like several drugs i don't know i
think you get like a paralyzing agent
first
like paralyze your body and then they
like stop your heart or whatever awful
things they do
um yeah uh so i wonder like how close to
dying like cletus got before the city
because obviously the symbiote needs
cletus to be alive to stay alive i bet
that like really pissed it off like
right from the start and i don't know if
because those drugs were going directly
into the bloodstream you see like the
red juice like fight back in the tube
but maybe some of it bonded in with two
and like really messed up the symbiote's
like personality and made it even more
evil it's also interesting to note that
in the comics carnage eventually has its
own offspring named toxin and perhaps
that could still come to fruition
somehow in the sony venomverse and it
would make sense since carnage's own
creation did involve the toxins of the
lethal injection cocktail and you know i
feel like because at the end of the
movie sort of did end with
you know cardiff being eaten by venom it
i feel like that did you you got the
ingredients there for a toxic baby i
feel like there you go because you got
the father and the son here comes the
holy spirit
venom like go get go get a vasectomy or
something you can't keep having these
kids jesus christ
you know yeah you're a menace
seriously okay get that thing snipped
no one needs more
no seriously uh it's not that bad sorry
i'm not gonna get to that um
it's the responsible thing to do venom
now let's think about the other
physiological attributes of cletus and
carnage like breathing and eating since
cletus and carnage are so closely linked
there really isn't a need for carnage to
provide oxygen to cletus like they're
sort of both the same being they breathe
together but that also means that
anything eaten by carnage is also eaten
by cletus but i feel like that dude's so
weird that he probably doesn't mind
he loves it
he's just like delicious is this this oh
is this oh blood
the best oh blood none of that a or b
[ __ ] oh delicious gives me an o in my
mouth
um anyway
there are no separate digestive systems
with green slime poop here though to be
fair cletus probably loves the ability
to eat people he loves the taste of
blood after all and knows what it's
supposed to taste like so he knows the
fine dining
of blood just
it's as if all he knows is fine dining
and breathing yeah if the carnage is
like
fully worked within his you know his
body it probably also is like worked
into his digestive system so yeah unlike
eddie who probably couldn't process
the bones of people uh i'm sure cletus
could do it with like carnage like
helping his stomach like do all the
nasty stuff and frankly it's mostly
because eddie's a little [ __ ] and he
just can't handle it just eat a person
and get over it he's a picky eater you
know he's like i don't want to eat
people just grow up eddie
and finally we should touch on carnage's
strengths and abilities because he was
first introduced in the comics to be
basically a venom 2.0 and to serve as a
foil for both spider-man and venom and
while venom may have some redeeming
qualities carnage was always intended to
be a straight-up villainous killing
machine as such he is often portrayed as
more powerful than both venom and
spider-man in the comics and we saw some
of that too here in the film and venom
was initially afraid to take on carnage
and eddie had to promise him that he
would break the all-important no-eating
people rule to coax him into fighting
carnage and that might partially be true
to the fact that carnage is a straight
killing machine but also because he is
an offspring of venom himself and we
mentioned toxin earlier carnage's
offspring in the comics and carnage was
constantly worried that toxin would
become more powerful and kill him so
maybe it's a thing that symbiotes fear
their offspring because they keep
getting more powerful very interesting
there i feel like yeah that'd be really
interesting like a societal thing it's
like i had a son but at what cost what
cost to me what did it cost everything
it reminds me of like uh the sith right
like the whole thing with the system
yeah that's exactly what i was thinking
of you train a sith like
sith junior you have your little sith
junior knight uh and then he's so he or
she is supposed to kill you at some
point or you kill them like
which it's insane because like if you're
constantly like training someone to be
more powerful than you you're always
going to be afraid that they're going to
come kill you especially when it's part
of the rules of being a sith fix your
rules exactly fix the rules awesome like
in the star wars comics like paw patrol
tries to get vader killed multiple times
because he's like crazy
he's gonna kill him but you also made
him this powerful palpatine what are you
thinking yeah it's like you wanted a
good assistant uh this is kind of your
fault my dude but yes carnage also has
the ability to create fully formed
weapons out of his symbolic goo and we
saw that with carnage's tendrils making
weapons and even shooting out those
little darts something that venom's
enemy the symbiote riot from the first
film was able to do as well and riot
made that blade to stab eddie with
almost killing him just before the
rocket launch and only carnage appears
to be able to make a variety of weapons
and maybe venom never learned the trick
at symbiote school it made him very
jealous over the years and that's why
his parents kicked him out of the planet
get out of here you're an embarrassment
you're right you go to earth
yeah yeah yeah yeah hungry hungry hippo
do us all a favor and get out of here
pop wait please maybe that's also like a
result of like yeah the the offsprings
are more powerful and they they get
better abilities as they go on i i don't
know i mean we saw like like you said we
saw riot make that kind of blade thing
with his goo in the first film so some
symbiotes can do it some can't i don't
know venom can't do it that's why he's
jealous all the time maybe he's too
stupid i don't know i wonder if like
some of the actual power of a symbiote
gets sapped away when they have a baby
like like some of their actual strength
it's like maybe venom is a little bit
weaker oh because he made an offspring
that's an interesting idea yeah i gotta
i got another thing for you to think
about mt do you think carnage is is so
evil because it's bonded with cletus
cassidy or do you think it would always
have been that evil
whomever i bonded with
that's actually a good question because
like what if like
the yeah the what if the the symbiote
becomes a manifestation of the person
that it initially bonds to that's what
sort of like a what came first the
chicken or the eggs right right right
nature versus nurture right yeah because
again the film's a little different than
the comic books because cletus bites him
and gets the blood into his bloodstream
and gets the symbiote into his
bloodstream and maybe even it's that
bonding on the blood level that makes it
less
less distinguished you know as you were
saying like there's not really a wee
with carnage there's an eye and is
that i is that the symbiote itself or is
that cletus taking over the symbiote or
the symbiote taking over cletus
right i think it's probably cletus
taking over the symbiote like if venom's
offspring had latched on to just like a
counterfeiter at the prison it would be
a totally different story we wouldn't
have all this all this carnage if you
will we have a symbiote
counterfeit or forgery
and you just go around writing bad
checks
that's all he would do and be a much
nicer life
like no i really do like that and like i
hope that they explore more of that
relationship than like how uh symbiote
gets formed in venom three because we
know they're good they're gonna make a
venom three that's gonna happen i mean
empty you and i are big nerds you know
we love all the action in the movies but
you and i just want like a three-hour
movie of someone interviewing the
characters telling us every little
detail about how their life functions
exactly it's like hey how was your
anatomy venom tell me how was puberty
for you then yeah that was a great fight
a lot of fun now i got 20 questions for
you for the next hour and a half of this
film well that was our look into the
anatomy of a symbiote and its host and
we'll have to wait and see if we get any
more symbiotes in either of the sony
venomverse or maybe even the mcu maybe
maybe maybe but sony certainly hopes
sony wants into that mcu but kevin says
everybody wants into that mcu before we
continue our merch partners at epic hero
shop have all kinds of cool clothing and
gear inspired by your favorite
properties and they just released a
shirt inspired by venom that there be
carnage that you need to check out and
pair it with their no way home tales of
the multiverse shirt and you can cross
cinematic universes in your closet in
ways that studios only wish that they
could and grabbing something from
newrockstarsmerch.com is an awesome way
to support the channel and to show the
world your love for your favorite fandom
and before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the
people that help us bring big question
to you people like mint mobile with big
wireless providers there's always a
catch and that's what's so cool about
mint mobiles offering a premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month there is no catch and mint mobile
secret sauce is that they're the first
company to sell wireless service online
owning they cut out retail stores so
that's less overhead that they pass on
to you and multiple members of the new
rockstar team have switched to mint and
they love it they get to keep their
phone their number and all of their
contacts while saving a buttload of
money and for people looking for extra
savings mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month and
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text plus high speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5g network and if
you're not 100 satisfied mint mobile has
you covered with their seven-day
money-back guarantee so switch to mit
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month so to
get your new wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
big q that is mittmobile.com
bigq big q cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month at mintmobile.com
big u what would you do if you didn't
have high interest loans or credit card
debt
i'd go hang gliding all the time with
upstart you could pay off your existing
debt quickly and easily and start living
your life especially on a hang glider
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income current
employment and credit history to find
you a smarter rate for your loan you can
check your rate without impacting your
credit score in minutes for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars you can even receive funds as
fast as one business day after accepting
your loan find out how upstart can lower
your monthly payments today when you go
to upstart.com bigquestion that's
upstart.com
b-i-g-q-u-e-s-t-i-o-n don't forget to
use our url to let them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application upstart.com bigquestion now
it is time for our bite-sized questions
my friend are you ready yum i like a
bite-sized
all right our first bite-sized question
of the day is if billy batson slash
captain marvel shazam says shazam in any
instance will he transform and what if
he says it by accident and this is from
bighead bubba on twitter thank you big
head bubba
that's a great question mt we all know
the original captain marvel shazam if
you will billy batson is the precocious
young boy in dc comics with the ability
to become the powerful superhero captain
marvel or shazam depending on who you
are just by uttering the phrase shazam
uh and if you didn't know the magic word
is an acronym for s the wisdom of
solomon h the strength of hercules a the
stamina of atlas z the power of zeus a
the courage of achilles and m the speed
of mercury
weren't golden age i prefer the dennis
model instead you like the dentist
i like dennis i don't like this separate
entirely so you guys noticed you know
you know captain marvel shazam the
character was recently brought into the
dc eu back in 2019 in the film shazam
exclamation point uh with a sequel
currently in the works uh in the early
days you know back in the golden age of
comics literally any time the word
shazam was said by billy the
transformation into or out of captain
marvel would occur you know with those
older comics this was like the major
plan of the villain was just to keep
billy from being able to say the magic
words like literally like the villains
would like put a handkerchief around his
mouth or like another villain like had
this machine that made everyone babies
so they couldn't say words i mean it was
just dumb wow you know it's actually
quite smart
stupid golden age
that's stupid golden age logic but
that's kind of smart i don't know it was
it was a simpler time folks comics were
just very precocious later on uh one of
captain marvel's sidekicks this guy by
the name of freddie freeman became
captain marvel jr uh and he had like a
similar magic word power-up because
uh
captain marvel took on the role of the
wizard and gave the powers to freddie
freeman to make him captain marvel jr
and so freddie's word to transform was
literally captain marvel instead of
shazam he would say captain marvel and
he would transform uh which made so that
means he couldn't even say like his own
name to people
because if they'd be like who are you
he'd be like
i can't say it or else
um
so
it was a little silly uh and at one
point batman even uses a recording of
freddie saying captain marvel against
him like in the middle of a fight
causing like captain marvel judy to just
like become de-powered during a fight
because he played like a recording of
him saying oh dang
so
all of these like saying the phrase
shenanigans got the old retcon when the
new 52 came around
and now the person has to have the
intention of
when they say the word in order to
transform i think that's a smart thing
to do
good job dc you know we've all grown up
a little bit comics they hit a little
harder now so adding adding the whole
like having the intention to transform
well was very good and this is like
probably very helpful also because again
as we've said in the comics and in the
film he goes by shazam now and not
captain marvel so if he had to say
shazam all the time it was just changing
it would be very confusing very
confusing indeed i really love how it's
kicking over how they just used to just
like cover his mouth it's like haha you
can't do it now some of those old comics
are very cute
it's very cute well i got another one
for you though
yeah all right well brandon what is the
difference between how the watcher
observes everything and how heimdall can
see every soul like other abilities
related and this is from flying land
leech on twitter thank you flying land
leech so we have heimdall and uatu the
watcher and they're definitely like the
biggest voyeurs we have in the marvel
universe
big perverts always checking in on the
others actions you know heimdall's
always like don't worry thor i'm
watching jane foster watching your girl
don't even worry about it or it's
probably like
she didn't ask you to do that i'm dog
cut it out buddy okay right
i took the liberty of watching your girl
yeah all right don't worry about it yeah
i mean
in the universe the biggest peepers we
have are uatu heimdal and santa claus
always checking in on you always
watching what you're doing
but are there powers of peeping the same
let's check it out okay so heimdall he's
odin's chosen gatekeeper of asgard um he
has like these incredible powers of
perception he can watch over 10 trillion
souls from his post in asgard he can see
why kids love the taste of cinnamon
toast crunch yeah he knows why he knows
why they love it uh he knows why tricks
are just for kids and mt it's not just
his site that's very powerful um
even from his post he was able to hear
like ladies sif in the warriors three
conspiring against loki when loki was in
charge of asgard even though he was
probably like listen i don't like loki
but he's the king now and i gotta
respect the king it's like a whole thing
and i guess he could probably smell
really well too like if you were like a
stinky bad guy he could smell you from
across the galaxy though it has been
shown that people such as loki are able
to hide their actions from heimdall uh
like in sneakers so you can't hide the
incognito
yeah yeah you turn on the incognito mode
no idea what you're doing poor jane
foster has no idea she's being watched
so like the comics you know again comics
really go deep on the powers and
abilities they've established that
heimdall can see and hear as far as
creation so that's the whole universe
right and it's also said that heimdall
can look across space and time uh so
that's it's pretty powerful though
heimdall isn't taking in all this
information at once uh it would probably
like overwhelm him you know be too much
he focuses his senses when he needs to
but for the most part he's just kind of
like watching out for threats against
asgard so yeah he can he can see 10
trillion souls but he's not doing it all
the time taking in all the information
and processing it he's just keeping an
eye out he's
poking around right poking around okay
so then if you look at uwatu so he's a
watcher and the watchers are one of the
oldest species in the universe uwatu and
the other watchers like they collect
knowledge on all aspects of the universe
without any interference they're not
supposed to get involved right
too loves to get involved
while watu watches much like heimdall
does uwatu also has the power of
telepathy so he can read the thoughts of
the people that he observes uh and
that's something heimdall cannot do uh
and most importantly owatu also has the
ability to look across multiple
universes and timelines right that's a
big difference like heimdall's just
stuck huge stars yeah but like he can
look at that
[Laughter]
like looking all over the place and now
finally probably the biggest difference
and i know i said important but this is
like the most important difference he
watch was able to break the fourth wall
and speak directly to the reader or the
viewer just like he does in the series
what if like he's talking to us and the
comics like guatu is talking to us
heimdall doesn't even know there's a
fourth wall he doesn't even know we're
watching we're peeping on heimdall he's
busy keeping it on james we're watching
heimdall okay even though the watchers
are immensely more powerful than even a
super-powered ass guardian like heimdall
they too can be taken by surprise uh as
we saw in episode seven of what if when
ultravision showed up kind of surprised
right uh so
you know they're not infallible but they
definitely have like greater powers of
perception uh but among the like
non-watchers i think heimdall is
probably the most
he's like right there he's like the most
powerful
sensor viewer watcher uh in the universe
so yeah basically heimdall watches
everything in our universe whereas law
two is just like i just well we got
international cable in this box i gotta
watch a lot of timeline time though i
don't get time for your bs
he's watching a trillion heimdalls you
just heimdall2487
i don't need you yeah i don't need you i
don't need your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well thank you brandon well it is time
for our favorite part of the show it's
time for the box of scraps ooh box of
scraps
since we are talking about venom a
cinematic universe that would love to
merge with the mcu
what would your dream crossover project
of any nerd universe
with the mcu that's a great question mt
uh mine would probably be and i'm gonna
kind of take this from the comics uh
because these were like uh when i was
reading a lot of comics as a youth uh i
loved like the alien versus predator
comics they were some of my favorites
they did some really cool crossovers one
of them being it was aliens versus
batman where he like goes down oh my god
yeah
temple and he has to fight aliens and
he's like what is going on like an alien
takes over an alligator you get like an
alligator alien it's great it's cool
stuff so what i would like to see i want
to see the aliens come to oh my god they
can too now yes i would love to see that
because they bought fox oh my god one of
those please the guardians are out there
in the cosmos they find one of those
eggs it opens up you know someone gets
infected they come back to earth they
bring the aliens to earth and now the
avengers have got to fight the aliens
that would be so cool
chest bursting action
i would love that
or even like even like uh they would
never do this a what if episode of like
what if like the ravagers have got like
uh an alien infestation of xenomorph
station that they had to deal with like
that would be just
like be so hilarious but like really
crazy and cool fighting with like marvel
characters i would love it it'd be so
cool oh my god so cool but like the the
marvel alien race the brood sort of
remind me of like the xenomorphs a
little bit so i've always wished that
they would sort of just lean into that
scary and stuff but yeah make it really
scary like i love to like the zombie
episode of what if but i want some more
some more fear some more sci-fi fear
right
let's get some a marvel horror [ __ ]
going like even though like new mutants
was fox and it wasn't very good i really
liked that they went they dived into
they tried it i really like that alien
idea i would love for alien to cross
over with the mcu um for me i think i
mean this is like uh a weird thing not
really all that weird but like i would
i've been dying to see the ninja turtles
oh
hell like freaking i think it would be
so amazing if like disney were to buy
the ninja turtles and like for the ninja
turtles to sort of slowly integrate into
the daredevil side of the universe with
like the hand versing the foot and like
the teenage ninja turtles teaming up
with daredevil and like doing more
street level um crime stuff even though
obviously justina owns everything and
like they don't need to own the ninja
turtles right but i think it'd just be
really cool that would be cool
new york centered story a little
daredevil you get some ninja turtles in
there
maybe iron fist shows up maybe shang chi
shows up like that would be a reason
like
like it's all set it's all set i'm into
that i love that i love the ninja
turtles you know what let's just do
the ninja turtles and the ravagers
fighting the alien
there we go and let's mash up all our
ideas together into one movie well that
is it for this episode of big question i
of course want to thank off-screen
producer brandon for joining me this
episode thank you so much brandon your
input is always valued please follow him
at grindenberric on twitter you can
follow me at mastertainment on twitter
if you want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] but most importantly please follow
new rockstars on twitter um at new
rockstars or you can just follow us on
youtube by hitting that notification
bell so you can get notifications
whenever we upload a video and also
don't forget to go to new
rockstarsmerch.com to get that venom
shirt because we got that shirt and all
sorts of cool shirts at new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can just be
cool like all your friends be cool
finally
just hurry up steven just be cool
already yeah anyway thank you guys so
much for watching we'll see you guys
later goodbye
[Music]
you